I don't want to be anywhere near you. That's incredibly insane
that you have like this like Oh yeah, you're probably right on
that conversation. But actually, you're like a totally you're
like a total psychopath, okay? And I don't want to be anywhere
near you. You record private conversations with your friends
in order to win arguments months later, weeks later. That's that's
weird. That's disgusting. And Molina talked to me and she was
like, "Hey, um if you're going to send any videos to um new girls
that we haven't talked about, like let me know that first." um
because she wanted to be careful and like okay sure that was
fine. I didn't think about it at the time because I didn't think
it mattered but uh I didn't think about it at the time because
I didn't think it mattered but uh but you know when my life when
my wife was like hey maybe don't send me non-conensually to people
well then it really dawned on me that that might not be okay.
Yeah sure this as well. Hey uh Destiny says you're a Kiwi farmer.
Do you have any proof that you're not? It's like no ask him for
proof. That's what you need to do. Ask him to prove his positive
claim that something's happening. You idiot. Where in the world
else would you act like
Okay, so let me find this again. Okay, we this pixie thing. All
right, so confused. Did I do something wrong? But I read out
a title of your subreddit.
No. Um, it was just going to take me longer to do it to get through
all of that stuff with m multiple people here and I wanted to
get on to this content as well. So, I see.
Yeah, we had um we had all of this stuff, right? Okay. So, it
started with the pixie thing. who was quote tweeting the Denims
thing. Uh, I thought this was weird for Ethan. I think this is
weird for Ethan who like claims to be just another Ethan moment
where he's like, "Oh, you disgusting. This disgusting is the
real Destiny orbiter. She wanted to him." I think that's very
weird. I just think that's very weird. What do you think, Kelly?
Do you think this is a cool opinion for Klein to have? It is
weird. I don't know why he cares.
This is strange. I think it's bizarre, but yeah, there was this
some people uh some people say the stuff up here. Oh, you never
thought I'd say I feel sorry for those guys. She plays victim
yet acts like a denim TV. Crawl back to the goblin cave from
whence you came. Be gone, e thought. Uh-huh. Jesus. Hold on.
Let's see. Being a woman is funny. And now you're starting to
understand why Pixie didn't want anyone to know. Uhhuh. Yeah.
Imagine only two people, one of them is Destiny, and then that
you over for months. Well, wait. Did she Did she actually do
it? Cuz if she did it, it wasn't at TwitchCon, right? Wasn't
Didn't she like not do it? I don't even know the actual circumstances
here. Right here, she's literally saying, "It sucks we didn't."
Yeah, sure. Denims, I don't think did. So, she that guy in his
bed and that was what all the drama was about. Yeah. Yeah. I
don't know. Yeah. Atlas. She Atlas in his bed apparently. So,
yeah. I don't know what that is. I don't know. But in any case,
I just This was very interesting. And then from here, Pixie quote
tweets this and says, "Actually reposting leaked DMs that were
that were only posted were only posted to humiliate someone speaking
out against crimes is disgusting behavior." Um, so I think Pixie
gets confused here and doesn't realize that Destiny had leaked
further DMs to humiliate Denims. So like this action literally
happened. These are just the wrong DMs that got leaked. So Denims
apparently leaked these herself, right? Yeah. But Destiny did
leak further DMs when uh when so it's just very funny because
he literally did this, right? He had to go to his Gmail and he
like he literally talked about on stream. He's like, "I have
to go to my Gmail and find these. Oh, here they are." And then
he po he like literally posts them, right? This happened like
after Denims was like, "Oh, he's a piece of [__]
for recording uh for recording me and for doing this to Pixie
and all." Yeah, he knows what she meant, too. He's just being
a
uh Did you hear Ethan? Minor spelling mistake vibes. Ah, it's
not quite that cuz Pixie is technically incorrect here. You should
be sharper than this, right? When you when you're trying to like
win sort of Pixie could not do this at all. I think Pixie shouldn't
do this, right? She shouldn't be trying to win like an optics
war with Destiny on Twitter. He's got way too many people who
will try to help him win it. It's just never actually going to
be valid, right? Like, it's never going to be a valid strategy
on her part. So, I I think she should opt out of it personally
or she should, I don't know, run these DMs run these tweets through
somebody else. Especially since his followers are like the most
obnoxious bot type responses most of the time, too. So, it's
not even like fun. They're like barely coherent idiots with like
zero followers. And it's just like this is sucks the fun out
of arguing with people on Twitter. Um, yeah. So, hold on real
quick. This is also the the the
notes or whatever. The community note is also goofy as to me
because again Pixie knows that this thing happened. I think she's
just confused about which DMs were leaked. It wasn't these DMs,
it was other DMs. And so the community note says user is lying
about who leaked these DMs and why. She's claiming streamer Destiny
leaked them. However, they were leaked by Denims herself. I think
it's just a clear misunderstanding, right? But uh it doesn't
matter because it's just astroturfed. It's whatever, right? Did
did Destiny not leak further DMs with Denims to humiliate her
would be the question I'd ask for any of these people, right?
Like Lex, we have a we have a cognitive cognitively individual
in chat right now. Lexer Q, you know that Destiny did leak further
DMs of a nature with DMs denims to try to humiliate her, right?
He leaked more of Lauren. We all know that's correct. What's
her faces the other day? Oh, Lauren de Laguna. Yeah. Is a definitely
a habit of his.
and he says, by the way, disgusting thing to do, but it it is
so it's just so funny that everything he's ever said in the past,
he just totally lied about, right? Oh, I'd never do anything
like he talks about like uh Byron and Andrew Tate and all these
other people who would like talk about people, right? Who would
like try to humiliate their their former partners and he would
go, "Oh, I'd never do anything like that. They're so disgusting."
And he's just totally gone back on that completely. Protest too
much. Whatever he protests about, he probably does. It's why
he freaked out over the foot fetish things. Yeah. Yeah. This
is just the weirdo people person is like the the sort of like
midwit take that a lot of people have which is why it's just
like weird for me to even try to support denims in any way or
like take her side cuz so many people are just willing to go
like no I don't have principles. I don't have any beliefs. I
have nothing. I just hate denims and any act against denims is
justified. There's like so many people on the internet who exist
like this in like this totally
state that she has the exception. Is it really the KG exception
when it applies? This is like actually Yeah, this is actually
like way more of the internet than you'd believe. Kelly is just
there's so many people who are like this. They like have no morals,
no principles, nothing actually concrete that they stand on whatsoever.
They're just like, "Oh, I really dislike this person." So, anything
done against them, that's awesome. I love it.
That seems like a terrorist mentality,
Um, Destiny went from saying he only nobodyies because they don't
have platforms and therefore something to gain to saying he doesn't
nobodyies because they have nothing to lose unlike people with
platforms. Well, no, no, no. I think he said I think he said
that he you shouldn't with people who have nothing to lose or
something. I think it's a little more complex than that, Dingling,
but that's not like totally far off. I don't think Pisco's audience
basically. No, that's totally wrong. I don't believe that's also
not true because he in the past banged loads of female Twitch
streamers that had a significant audience. Sure. He's just
Uh I got downloaded on LSF for saying it's kind of up. People
wish Tectton would die and don't care if he gets banned. Unjustified.
People have zero principles. Yeah, true.
Anyway. Anyway, so I think Destiny quote tweeted this, right?
Yeah. So Destiny goes on to quote tweet this. The per this person
is publicly stirring the pot against me in a public forum where
they have zero accountability for what they say. Meanwhile, she
cried in in the court in an attempt to get them to seal the transcript
of our hearing, which is under oath because she claimed it would
make her Wait, is that is that even remotely accurate to what
happened? Hold on. Uh I thought I thought there was like uh basically
that it had information like contained information as to witness
identities. Yeah, that's that is what was given. We can just
look at how accurate that is. There's no way he just like pops
up and lies here completely. Is there Hold on. I'm just looking
for It's just a woman hating line. Oh, she cried and got her
own way. Women bad.
Yeah, pretty much. I not this. Yes. Motion to seal attorney.
Honestly, it's so bizarre seeing one of the women from his community
that he held up with like actual esteem as being a really nice
person get this level of treatment. Like if you saw me getting
this from him, you'd be like, "Okay, whatever. That's Kelly Jean."
But like it's from my p it's really disorienting.
Like for him to be like this to Pixie of all people. I don't
know. It's just like what the [__] is wrong with
this guy? Um yeah, let's let's check out what it says. So Jane
Doe, pursuant to local rule 5.4 of the Southern District of Florida,
federal rules of civil procedure 26 C1 and 15 USC 6851 and hereby
respectfully request this court that the transcript of the evidentiary
hearing on the preliminary injunction the transcript be filed
under seal. In support thereof, Jane do states as follows. The
evidentiary hearing with regards to plaintiff's motion for temporary
injunction and preliminary injunction temporary restraining order
but uh was conducted on June 3rd, 2025. The transcript which
has yet to be published or filed contains highly sensitive private
and confidential information including personal details with
regards to the identity of Misdo details concerning Misau's harm
and suffering because of defendants's actions and explicit content.
Finally, a transcript under seal is necessary to protect the
privacy and confidentiality of the information of the information
contained therein. Plaintiff requests the seal remain in place
for the duration of the litigation including any appeals to ensure
ongoing protection of the identities of the witnesses.
This duration is consistent with the need to prevent further
emotional and psychological harm to the plaintiff and the individual's
reference in her testimony as supported by do Williams v. Williams
2024 US district something this is a yeah it's just a legal citation
which was noted which noted that 6851 purpose is to protect against
the public publicization of intimate matters. I'm just going
to point out to the baffle people in chat, yes, it can be sealed
and just because people can go to an open court, they're not
allowed to take their phones in. You're not allowed to record
it. They specifically take your phones off in the UK. I don't
know about the US. I'm pretty sure they're not This is not like
publicly available in that way, right? So, you know, I don't
know what you're confused about. Sure.
So, um I'm trying to see here. I don't see any I don't see if
it's like actually been sealed yet. Right. Taking notes not the
same as taking video or recording, is it dumbass? Which is like
actually it's the exact it's the exact example. Oh, Lexer is
actually too stupid to understand. Which is really common. It's
basically always the case with Lexer. So, he's too dumb to understand
that you can have like publicly available testimony and they
can actually say, "No, no, no. You can't uh you can't take video
cameras in here, right? You can't have an exact thing, but people
can go and view it and take notes." So, this is why you get court
sketches of people. Yes. You ever you ever see the court sketches
of Diddy from the recent trial? It's like you can't actually
take a picture or record in any way. You can take notes, but
you you can't do you can't actually uh like record in some way.
Yes, those are real. Uh all like court sketches are real. Absolutely.
Yes. Seeing the bad ones is funny. The guy like can't draw good.
The sketches are just bad. Why are you What is this that you're
linking?
Uh, is this relevant to what we're discussing right now, how
much [__] he can lie about and make up on his stream.
Um, and also, oh, is this about I think that's probably my guess
is a criminal international entity. And I feel like
to me,
oh, Kelly can't see. Kelly can't see. Kelly can see now. I had
to go back anyway. So, I feel like this is kind of how they're
trying uh the plaintiff is trying to do this case where she's
trying to publicly not say much about it, but she's coordinating
with a ton of people in the background who aren't a part of the
case who can say a lot about it. I think that's probably my guess
is I can't know this. My guess is that's probably why um Juicealker
didn't want to formally join the case is because then he would
probably be a lot more limited about how much he can lie about
and make up on his What the [__] Um, I think
be able to Yeah, I think Destiny should be able to respond to
anything I say on stream, right? Like I think um obviously the
only thing I wanted the protect I want the protective order to
keep my name out of his hands cuz he's actually expressed that
he would publish it immediately and I believe he's tried to.
So like I I think I have every concern and every right to be
concerned, but as far as me talking on stream, I think he should
be able to respond to anything I said on stream. I would love
if he just took the things I said on stream and actually responded
to them, but he actually never does. He never responds to the
things I say on stream. He just makes up what I said. He's just
accusing pictures of stuff he does. Like he was behind the scenes
making up lies about me being in a Discord server with Lav spreading
his revenge and making it with her and being like a primary there.
None of this stuff ever happened. He was doing that and he said
it all to Willie Mack privately. Like he's been doing the same
thing. I'm sure he said that same thing to a bunch of other people.
He's the one that's being like a Mavelian weirdo behind the scenes
and staring the Yeah, I would totally love if he'd just take
the exact things I say and respond to them instead of making
up things I said and responding to those things, right? That'd
be awesome.
Oh, this guy thinks he's Littlefinger, but he's just stupid.
I don't know.
Anyway,
funny got
sure. Did you see Destiny's logs in DG chat where he claimed
Pixie admitted Abby didn't show Pixie and her legal evidence
uh of him sharing videos of Pixie? I didn't see those logs, but
again, simply substance. I have no way to respond to any of that
until the transcript is out, right? I I literally can't I have
no way to say, "Oh, Destiny lied about this or Destiny's wrong
or Destiny's correct." I have no I just his his representation
which I've given I've been given every reason not to trust. He
lies constantly. Right? I've been given every reason not to trust
his recollection of things. Okay. That's the only representation
of that court hearing that we have because shockingly despite
what he says right here, I would never go and ask Pixie when
things are under seal and I'm concerned that eventually he'll
try to subpoena my Discord logs, right? I would never go ask
Pixie, hey, can you tell me what happened in that in that hearing?
Lex Q, I just gave you a straight up lie that he's told behind
the scenes and did you have your like hearing aid out at the
time or something? I don't um Lex is just too engaged for the
rest of this and he's going to he's just going to be like a total
uh I'm just going to time him out. He can come back tomorrow.
Like he's he's just going to sit here and concern troll the whole
time. He's just going to be very boring.
This man compared himself to Little Finger. Okay, I'm just playing
that. Yeah, sure. I'm just like explaining to everybody that
like I would totally have a discussion with that person if they're
operating in any sort of good faith, but they're just not. Oh
yeah, he did make some weird comments about Star recently. No
reason considering how quiet she is about everything. Yeah, Destiny's
fans won't do to you violently, but that doesn't mean you won't
be hacked or slaughtered with. So more guns or whatever is just
silly. Oh, I So I don't know about the fans. I think the fans
are schizophrenic. I dude when he tells when he says like I deserve
to get killed or somebody should go kill me. Uh that is concerning.
It's absolutely concerning. He is nothing like Reek because Reek
was able to um redeem himself. How is this stupid fat going to
redeem himself?
Just going to bully more people.
Anyway, so we continue on from there. I Oh, sorry. We're still
listening. Hold on. the case is because then he would probably
be a lot more limited about how much he can lie about and make
up on his stream. Where did I lie or make something up? I just
What did I lie or make up? Where where did that happen? He just
says it happened. Doesn't bother to have a clip. Doesn't bother
to have any evidence of this. He just says it happened. Where
am I lying or making something up? Where did that happen? Don't
you notice that? So, here's just the difference. And OMFG, he's
pro and everybody else who kind of likes Destiny a little bit.
I want you to observe the difference when I'm when I'm saying
or when I'm trying to figure out what Destiny's talking about.
When I'm responding to something Destiny said, I pull the clip
up and listen to the thing he said so you can see it and then
I respond. You'll notice that that is not something Destiny does,
right? He doesn't pull the clip of me doing something and then
respond to it. He just says that I'm doing a thing. I just It's
a very clear difference. It's one that he's pointed out constantly
as the way that Vos lied and manipulated people into believing
that he was a bad person. This was the exact tactic. He's described
it perfectly to people before, right? He is just going to build
a simulacum of who I am. He is never going to actually address
the things I say or any of my arguments. He will literally only
make up the things I said and respond to those. He pulled up
a clip of me. It's only audio. Well, I he does pull my clips
occasionally, but when he says I'm lying or coordinating with
Kiwi Farms or when he makes the actual major character indictments,
that will only be when he doesn't have a clip to site, right?
How do you coordinate with the entirety of Kiwi Farms? Do we
have null on speed dial or something? I don't know. We do not
tragically tragically we do not. Kelly just knows how to choose
perfect women victim. Guy's a nut job. Guy is a nut job. And
also Oh my god. Thank you. Um, it didn't come up at the hearing
today, but one of the strongest arguments I have, oh my god,
I'm sorry. One of the strongest arguments I have against all
of these witnesses saying, "I'm terrified of Destiny. I'm so
scared. I, you know, I think he's going to is that they make
public statements."
Um, okay. Again, this is Destiny. Destiny has relied on this
core like fallacy the entire time and that's the clear and obvious
difference between okay between your IRL identity the thing that
is tied to like the rest of your life and an online pseudonym
right he's like oh this online pseudonym made comments about
me that shows they're not afraid of me so they should be able
to put their identity into this court filing because they've
shown by using this online pseudonym to to comment that they're
not afraid that is so fake that is so false that is so obviously
untrue right? That is so obviously untrue that you have to be
an actual to believe that or not understand it. But it's what
almost all of his arguments rely on. Go ahead, Kelly. You don't
even have to be scared, right? Maybe just for like business reasons,
it wouldn't be ideal for your real name to pop up in a court
dock if in the future you want to go back to job. Right. That's
not being scared. That's just being practical and not stupid.
So, I don't There's like a bunch of reasons why it's a negative.
Yeah. And by the way, there's a whole other thing that basically
there are people who have come forward and said Destiny did this
and then when they go silent, they stop getting harassed, right?
So they could say something and then go back to wherever they
were and not not do it more. It's it's literally like a like
a natural I'm not saying he's coordinating it, but it's like
a natural coercive mechanism, right? Basically, you go post on
Twitter, people are going to be in your replies talking about
how you how you're a piece of [__] But if you don't
talk about it, you stop talking about it, it becomes like fine
over time, right? Yeah. He's generally the maddest out of the
people he's been unable to suppress. It's where all of his anger
is directed.
Yeah. Yep. Anyway, we can a doctor come after me. I'm so sorry,
Stacia, and all you other you guys talk about this every single
day in Justic's Discord server. I have hundreds of pages of you
talking about it. Did he just say just go through just Yeah,
just go through the logs. He pretends he doesn't know the name,
right? He totally was like really good friends with this person,
had constant conversations with them, and he pretends that he
doesn't understand the name. Um,
okay. Why is he suddenly bringing her up? That's pretty weird.
I just I just love like I this is just like a subtle thing, but
like the absolute like uh like child physio that's going on here
um is very very funny. I don't think he's I'm not claiming that
he's touched kids. I'm just saying that if you did a the composite
of all people who have touched kids like their mug shots, it
would come out as Destiny's face, right? If you did a composite
and got the average, it would like just be Destiny's face currently.
I mean, he has average child, so he's got that as a bonus going
for him. I just think
that blends in at a central casting. Yes. Central casting who's
like luring kids into a van with candy is basically Destiny's
entire vibe now. Is very funny.
Ah.
God, this is so perfect. Anyway, and I think that's like it's
like that's that's proof of like the supernatural existing in
some way, right? It's it's proof of the supernatural existing
because as he becomes like a person, he takes actions. He transforms
more and more in a phys physio sense, physioy
sense. Okay. In terms of his looks, he transforms more into somebody
who looks like a child predator. He's not, by the way. I'm not
making that allegation. I'm saying he looks like Yeah. Anyway,
yeah, I see it. Also, like Stacia stuck up for his girlfriend
when I was being mean quotation. So, I wonder why he suddenly
turned on her.
Yeah. Makes you think.
Uh, it does make you think that constantly you can't talk about
something in a public facing area for weeks and months at a time
and then when it comes time for you to testify, come out and
be like, "Um, well, actually, I'm too scared because I'm worried
that uh he's going to come down really harshly on me." It doesn't
work that way. You're either scared or you're not. You can't
have it both ways.
Oh, is that here or is that there? That's there. Hey, what's
up? What do you want?
Okay. Anyway, we're we're good. This is going to be I think him
and his buddy going over the uh the transcript. I said nothing
to go back with. So, done. Y are you continuing this or uh yeah,
we're uh No, we're not. Well, sorry. This was um the identity
of the witnesses and then basically details about Ms. Do and
uh details with regards to the identity of Miso. If there are
if there are details like regarding her personal identity, that
would be a valid argument. If there's just details pointing to
her pseudonym, this would not be a valid argument. This did remind
me of something that happened, I think this was a bit further
ago, but I don't think we spoke about it, where he where all
of the um topic of um getting stuff taken down in Kiwi Farms
came up, right? And all Destiny did was send a single email to
Null. And Null has maintained from the start, you need a court
order. and him not doing that for some arbitrary reason and now
fighting actively against it. I do think that is strange. Is
that just a stubbornness thing or is it him being cheap again
and not wanting to pay for a court order? Um, wait, sorry, say
that again. I missed what you were talking about. Um, so Null
brought up like that he he still he'd never made a court order
to get stuff taken down. All he'd done is send a singular email.
And there's been like recent correspondence for him being against
the concept of a court order to get stuff taken down. Obviously
Pixie's doing her own one, but he won't just pay to get his own
one done and is actively against the concept for some reason.
Yeah. It's just it's it's just total disingenuity. Like he he's
not genuine at all. Right. Yeah. I just don't know why. It's
so bizarre. He's a total piece of He's just a completely deranged
lunatic. Yeah. Yeah, but I'm just trying to figure out the motivation
behind him not paying to get the rest of his revenge taken down
because all this pixie stuff's gone, right?
Um, yeah, he didn't want to pay for it. I don't know why he didn't
want to pay for it. Yeah, I have no idea. Cheap. No clue. Or
stubborn both question. I don't know. It was just strange. Uh,
substance. That's going to come up in these in these messages
we're looking at right now. In fact, you gave me that recording
to the that situation. Dims was clearly lying. Sure,
but this is again, I guess, totally disingenuous, right? So,
I don't think that I don't think that Destiny, you know, saying
that he was wrong. Like, it seems like Denims did try to lie
about him, right, four years ago. Like, she was saying, "Oh,
because I Atlas, like this guy stopped talking to me, he started
treating me like seemed like that wasn't quite true necessarily,
right? I think even these DMs that are in the Ethan thing, I
think that's even like disingenuously clipped or something. He
looks like he's melting.
He doesn't think that null will take it down even with a court
order. So he doesn't even try. Well, thinking that he won't do
it even doesn't isn't a good reason for not doing it, is it?
Because then he can say, "Oh, I did do it and null ignored me,
which would be a good argument for him making the effort to the
court." But instead, he's decided to he sent like his email.
Well, he sent his email, which was clearly not going to do anything,
right? Yeah. Obviously. Yes.
Yeah. The idea that his email, the idea that his email is proof
of a good faith effort to get his taken down. I just can't see
anybody believing that. You'd have to be like such a to believe
that was a good faith attempt to get his uh his taken down from
Kiwi Farms. Like there's just no way you could possibly go, "Yeah,
him saying, "Hey, I I I believe there's revenge on me on your
website. Could you could you go here and take it down?" Like
there's no attempt to engage in a dialogue. He doesn't even follow
up, right? It's it's bizarre that you would say that. is so bizarre.
Destiny also, no. OMFG, he's pro. You're absolutely incorrect
there. That's not the point Destiny was making. When Destiny's
lawyers requested that it all get taken down, they said, "Oh,
could you please reimburse us for this?" And then I believe they
said, "No." Right? Pixie's lawyers didn't say, "No, we won't
take your stuff down." They said, "Hey, we would want to be reimbursed
for the cost of engaging with Kiwi Farms because your client
hasn't done that." They just asked for their fees to be covered.
Right. If you want way more work done on your behalf, could you
cover our fees for doing this? Yeah. And Destiny's lawyer said,
"No, as far as I understand,
right?" They said, "No." So, Destiny could have had all his stuff
taken down if he just agreed to pay. No, OMFG. He's pro. You're
wrong. That's just wrong based on the evidence. I don't And I
don't even believe Destiny would would accuse her of that because
that would be clearly disproven by the court documents. Like,
I link me the clip of Destiny saying that a re reimbursement
is reasonable, right? It's a per cost per item, right? Well,
I don't know if it's cost per item, Sophia. But it would totally
make sense that so the argument that uh Destiny's team makes
is oh it's really inappropriate to pay legal fees before the
court the case is settled. But in that case where they'd be removing
the stuff for Destiny or asking Kiwi Farms to remove the stuff
for Destiny, they would be doing work that they wouldn't be able
to recoup their costs from if they lose the case, right? So they
would ask for them to be covered now, which seems pretty obvious
to me. You'd never ever ask a contractor to work on the, you
know, 50/50 chance that you will be able to pay them. That's
goofy. Yeah, it's Yeah, it's just weird also for them to be taking
down like the content that doesn't even have Pixie in it. I just
That just seems weird. Like a conflict of interest almost. It's
like maybe you should do that with your legal team. This is just
weird for them to be I don't know. I know that they said that
they would if they were paid, but it still feels weird. Sure.
Pay your own damn lawyers to do that work for sakes. Sure. Sure.
There's like a couple things going on there. Yeah. Sure. Um,
there's, yeah, there's like a couple things going on there. Um,
I don't know. I don't know if they'd have jurisdiction to take
down the non-pixie Destiny video, right? They might only have
So, Destiny's made the argument that the other videos are totally
irrelevant to the case. If that argument is correct, I believe
they would not have the ability to order those other those other
videos taken down as a part of this case, right? the the video
that is at the core of this case. If the video they're requesting
being taken down, why would they be able to have like jurisdiction
to do totally unaffiliated
or un uh what do you call it? Unrelated. Why would they be able
to do takeown claims on unrelated content? So, if he if he's
going to claim that those are totally unrelated, then I don't
understand how he could also expect Pixie to take his stuff down.
Yeah. Null also said like he made some exceptions, right? He
wasn't being super stringent on things. He just said he wanted
a cool order and this guy has made no effort in the last 6 months
to do that. So, I don't know. Yeah. Yeah. If he had tried and
failed then okay, but he didn't even try. It's just
Kind of bizarre. Yeah. Kind of bizarre.
Anyway, we're not even to the actual content yet.
I did say that from the start. Okay. From here, I think we go
to the sleepy devo quote tweet. I think this is the quote tweet.
Yes. Okay.
So, Dev Short Fataku goes on Twitter and I still have a message
out to him. Hey, we're going to cover this stuff tonight. Hey,
Dev, do you want to respond? Hello, Dev. I'm going to say one
second. Sorry. How am I defending anyone? Kelly is defending
the guy who's living out revenge of her friends on his site.
Lol. Where am I defending who? I'm simply stating null said this
process I will then take stuff down. You didn't do that for that
person. That's not somebody who's been here very long. That's
just a concern troll is a total just how am I defending? I'm
just saying what they said. Stupid [__] Yeah, that
person is just going to try to take up your time. They're never
going to like actually engage in any way. Just Just letting you
know if you see other messages from that person, they're probably
just trying to with you. They have no interest in actually like
points or anything.
I'm responding to things anyway. Hey, that person, Kelly, that
person's just trying to take up your time. I know that. I'm responding
to them anyway. It's like, okay, all right. You take up my time,
too, and I respond to you as well, so what's your problem? Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Okay. Destiny legitimately has some behavior he needs
to apologize for and make amends for in this story. Pixie has
clearly been using the court system in bad faith, making untrue
claims, using the process to silence criticism. Um, neither of
these wash away the other. Both are true. It's like, uh, okay.
Um, I would just love to see I I would love to walk through this
with Dev. And I actually just messaged Dev and said, "Hey, I'm
going to review your tweets right now. I would just love to see
like where this argument is coming from and what proof and evidence
he has for these things, right? And and I would love to see,
you know, is he putting these opinions on Twitter? Because you
can have opinions that are wrong. Okay, you can totally have
opinions that are wrong. But then like when somebody asks you,
you should probably be able to produce evidence for your opinions.
Yes, you're putting the onus on Destiny/ such [__]
to do anything. Why doesn't null just not be a piece of human
scum and remove revenge? You have no smoke for him. Oh. Oh, it's
the Never mind. My bad, dude. J, what the [__] do
you want Kelly to do on stream exactly? It sounds like you just
want her to be a trained pet, get a dog or something. No, I'm
just telling her that, hey, there there are obviously people
who just have no interest in trying to engage in any kind of
good faith. Okay, weird people, you are Discord or banned, you
can join the Discord right now if you like. Hop in the Discord.
Okay, hop in the Discord. Hop in the waiting room, then you can
come on stream and make your point. Okay, I'm going to read out
a nice message because otherwise you'll complain. I'm only reading
out trolls. Someone said, "Uh, I don't come by often, but I enjoy
your input, Kelly, even if you are British." That was a wrong,
but it's okay. Thank you. Wow. No, Toad. Okay. Fast. Anyway,
so Destiny will probably win the court case as I don't think
the available evidence rises to that level. I don't believe that
means he's innocent of all wrongdoing. Far from it. Meanwhile,
Pixie's own victimization doesn't give her a free pass to be
unhinged and weaponize the system. So, I would like to see, you
know, where where she's weaponizing it. But hold on. This LE
person has come along and said, "Hey, what are you talking about?
What are you talking about here? What are you talking about?"
And it's so funny because she actually makes great argu I read
a couple of the replies in this thread. I think she makes some
really great points and she's like not getting likes at all.
It's very funny to me. Anyway, so I've since looked over the
whole case. Destiny is far from innocent, but so is Pixie. Turns
out she shared the tape with people behind his back as well last
I checked. Plus, her actions in court have been uh not great.
So, unless Dev has some evidence that I'm unaware of, Pixie said
she claimed with consent that she'd sent the video to her boyfriend.
There are no other people. There's just one person is her boyfriend.
Her boyfriend at that time, right? That was in the the actual
official record weeks ago. Weeks almost a full month ago now,
right? So, there's no new revelation that occurred. Um, yeah,
OMFG, he's pro. I don't need to know. That's cool. Um, we'll
see in the transcript when it comes out. Oh, so you just believe
the thing that Destiny completely lied about. Well, we don't
know that he completely lied about it, right? We don't know what
Pixie said, but I don't think Pixie's testimony in open court
would necessarily overwrite her like sworn testimony. The inconsistency
might be concerning, but she said with consent, I sent this video
to my boyfriend, right? It's it's explicitly Destiny said he
would send it to Molina. I said I would send it to my partner,
right? My committed partner, your committed partner. We're okay
with that. Uh Sandre Wave, we might check it out in a little
bit. We're on some content right now. Oh, so you Oh, so you just
believe the thing Destiny completely lied about. Whatever. Not
worth arguing with anyone who still takes his word as gospel.
Let me know if you ever break out of that. So Dev says, "If you
have proof he lied, I'd like to see it. As I said, I've been
looking." So right there, this line right here, Dev, I hope you're
watching cuz you've been not responding to my DMs even though
any other time I've messaged you in the entire history we've
been friends, you messaged me back like immediately. Okay. You
are so good at messaging back. You are so perma online. And today
you've not responded to me at all. All I've said is, "Hey, can
we uh can we talk?" But this is the most thing I've ever seen.
Okay, not actually, but it's pretty. Okay, if you have proof
he lied, I'd like to see it. Basically, you make a positive claim
something happened. And she goes, "No, that's up." Like, where's
your proof of that? Like, who's who's you just taking Destiny's
word on that? Even though he's lied a lot in the past on this
case, he's literally just lied. Uh, and and Dev says, "If you
have proof he lied, I just prove that he's not telling the truth.
Prove that Pixie prove that Pixie sent it with consent." Right.
Not not not that. Sorry. Prove that Destiny is lying for a transcript
that is sealed. And when there's evidence that Pixie said a contra
uh controverting controverting statement in previous testimony,
look at this. DG logs. He had a fanboy orgasm over D replying
to his tweet. Oh, gross. That happens a little ways down here.
Anyway, so if you have proof he lied, I'd like to see it. So
we don't need proof he lied. We need the proof from him and that
dev. This is what counterpoints did, too. He's actually doing
Yes, it is. This is short fatu. Yes, this is short fataku. So
when we look at this, counterpoints did this as well. Hey, uh
Destiny says you're a Kiwi farmer. Do you have any proof that
you're not? It's like, no. Ask him for proof. That's what you
need to do. Ask him to prove his positive claim that something's
happening. You idiot. Where in the world else would you act like
this? Like at what point do I just go, "Oh, Deb's like Deb's
like totally." And I thought, "By the way, I think Deb's like
a good person. I think he's very intelligent. I've always like
shuttered him out on my channel." And this this right here, if
you have proof he lied, I'd like to see it. No, I'm we're asking
for what proof you have that he was telling the truth. What proof
did he provide that his word is good on this? He made a positive
claim and has done nothing to back it up and has lied in similar
situ similar situations in the past and is acting like this was
a revelation when Pixie said I sent it to my boyfriend months
ago. Yeah. Uh true gigas grand actually that is a great point.
Yeah. I'm claiming that Dev Short Fataku is a and if he has proof
that he's not a I'd like to see it. Okay. I'm just saying I listen
if he has proof that he's not a I'd love to see that. Please
Dev, please prove that you're not
Okay, we go from here. The LEB person keeps going, "Where did
you get the idea that she shared it with people behind his back?"
Dev says, "Reading the Ka thread, I think I've archived everything
I've seen for a future video on the topic. If you have evidence
it's wrong, send it my way and I'll archive that, too." Oh, is
Destiny about to dox Dev? Is Dev taking Kiwi Farm's conjecture
as fact. I think I think Dev has unknowingly just unlocked Destiny's
just allowed to dox you now. I hope he's aware of that. He can
literally never turn on Destiny because he's taken Kiwi Farm's
conjecture, which I've never done, by the way. Even though Destiny
has said so, I've never done that. All right. But Destiny has
said, "Oh, if you if you believe things on Kiwi Farm that aren't
sourced, okay, you're you're insane. You're unhinged and you're
actually helping Dachon and Swap My Family." That's Destiny's
position. Okay, so I've archived everything I've seen for a future
video on the topic. If you have evidence is wrong, send it my
way, and I'll archive that, too. Clearly, it didn't originate
in that KF thread. I'm asking you what evidence you saw to support
it, which is exactly the point. By the way, anybody who will
defend using KF as a source, right? It's not, hey, this guy put
together like a bunch of threads and and made like some completely
crazy theory about this creator. That's not the you source off
of Kiwi Farms. When they archive a post or a video from the actual
creator in question, that's when it's cool to source them. That's
when it's like, "Oh, I'm going to take that and source it."
obviously
don't fully recall, which is why I said in the original tweet
last I checked, I know I have it stuffed away somewhere, but
I'm open to being wrong. What do you have? No, Dev, this is not
This is not Dev. Dev Dev, you're making positive claims. Dev,
Dev, Dev, you're making positive claims. You need to actually
source your positive claims. And you're saying that you archived
it. You're saying I have the reason I think this and I will if
I if I make a video later. Dev, you know, you've told me specifically
that you've done a bunch of research for videos that you've never
made. How about you just back up your opinion now? It would take
less time that it took you to continue replying in this thread.
Actually, just go do it. It's super not difficult. Uh I bleach.
Thank you for the gift of sub to freckles. And Sophia, thank
you for the gift of sub to freckles. Both of you gifting freckles.
That's uh that's crazy. But thank you both for gifting him. Okay.
Appreciate it. Appreciate it. Appreciate it. appreciate you guys.
Am I am I crazy? And like dev is Dev is somebody who could make
who could articulate this precisely, right? Dev would never be
somebody who's like he would never defend someone else who is
saying, "Well, I have evidence of this. I know that I I know
there's a reason I think this, but I will not look into why I
think this. In fact, will you show me why I shouldn't think this?
Show me the negative evidence for this." Okay? Nobody would do
this. He would never defend somebody else making this argument.
It's totally unhinged,
right? But again, he's getting like mass likes from I assume
DJers or he's got an audience of his own. I think he's got like
5 10,000 followers, 11.8K.
And but I I'll just say repeatedly, I'm like friends with this
guy. Like I I like this guy. I've I've like recommended him to
so many other people that like his his really good. And he's
he's embarrassing me right now. He's embarrassing me. Okay, you're
embarrassing me in front of my friends. Dev, what the are you
doing? Okay. So, again, I would just expect him to go get his
evidence, right? Hopefully, he goes and gets his evidence. Let's
see what the other replies are to this that aren't from Ellie.
When somebody makes a claim, the burden of proof is typically
on them to prove the claim. Yeah, obviously. Yes, he's reporting
on the hearings that Pixie took a similar implied consent approach.
The transcripts aren't out yet, but if he's lying, he'd be screwed.
Well, I would say also just basically that she already said she
had explicit consent before, so I don't know what's going on
there. Uh, Subbox Society, thank you for the gifted subs. Holy
10 gifted. Huge 10 gifted. Thank you very much. That's 12 gifted
on the stream. We are we are two subs and or $10 away from another
2 hours on the stream. So, we get going for a long time right
off the bat. Okay. Uh yeah, based thank you very much. Soapbox,
thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay, so we can go on to Ellie's
responses now. I just wanted to see some of the other responses
from some people. I'm not on the board this month. I have to
catch up. Based love the idea that you you should probably Soap
box what you want to do is uh is catch up to I drink bleed. No,
don't don't don't. I'm just I'm kidding. Thank you very much
for the support. I appreciate it. All right, let's look at uh
Ellie's responses here. What I have is a bit uh what I have Oh,
what do you have? What I have is a pretty big problem because
I know where it came from. A completely baseless claim from Destiny
about an event that his close friend claims he doesn't remember.
Uh which is counteracted by earlier court filings and his own
words. This is very important as well that not so erodite herself
said destiny told me directly that he thinks he did not have
consent to share it right and now now his own things are oh I
I did have consent right so Arerite went on did the turkey Tom
interview and said explicitly destiny told me well I don't remember
for sure but I I you know I'm pretty sure I didn't have consent
which actually backs up everything people were saying from before
where he says where where when he says I violated her her trust
in the worst of ways, he obviously means her consent, right?
So, it's just it's contemporaneous evidence to back up the claim
that when he says, "I violated her trust in the most egregious
way possible, in the worst way possible," he means her consent.
She regrets it now. Lol. Oh, we might watch that in a little
bit here. A Shakur, we might probably smacked her around for
saying that. Like, okay, I I'm almost positive that Aerodite
probably benches more than Destiny. I actually don't think that
Destiny could fight her. Destiny is act Destiny almost certainly
has lower testosterone than not soite. 70% of women on the planet.
Okay. I can show you the NC clip on Tom if you like. Oh, sure.
Send that my way. Yeah, let's check it out. This is why I think
it's important to maintain the expectation that people who make
affirmative claims against his victims should be able to substantiate
them because his strategy is clearly to damage his victims to
try and shut them and other victims up. This is totally why would
this ever be bad, right? This is a totally reasonable thing to
say. Like this is this is maybe the most reasonable thing I've
ever read on Twitter. Like, hey, I think um probably when you
make a positive claim, you should be able to substantiate that
with evidence that isn't just the word of another person, especially
if it's like harmful, right? That's so reasonable. Yo, can someone
give me myself? Ah, we have to check that out. So, apparently
Israel bombed Iran today. Me, that's crazy. We'll have to check
that out after this. Uh,
so the next tweet here is, "I will send you what I have, but
it's untenable for Steven to be able to come out with a new smear
every day and the burden to be placed on his victims who are
in an impossible position regarding defending themselves publicly
to disprove them." Yeah, it's totally reasonable. I hope Deb
respond, "Well, I don't want anybody to shut up because of what
I posted, and I don't think that'll happen. I have no reach."
That's not true. In fact, you have you have like four times her
likes on all these tweets. Trust me, if you are willing to defend
Destiny through this, you will have a lot of reach. you'll have
all kinds of reach. That's why Destiny, by the way, I I will
say we go down a little bit. Spoilers, that's why Destiny comes
and replies in this thread, right? That's why he comes and replies
in this thread because Destiny wants Dev to have more reach.
Yeah, Destiny wants Dev to have more reach with this, right?
That's why he's doing it. It's in the R. Yeah, we'll watch too.
It's a woman as well. He's seething extra hard because it's a
woman that's an anti fan. Have you seen how angry he is at anything
Zoe's ever said? Right. or shell owner as well. Oh, when he tried
to point Yeah. He is so angry that he tries to that he tries
to push harassment towards Zoe Jacob again and again and again.
He's a loser. Anyway, yeah, it's just funny how a guy can say
the same thing, but if a girl says it, he just gets far more
rationally angry. It's great. Sure. Let's uh let's read the next.
You may you may not want that, but you're contributing. That
is um people shutting up. Let's say for argument sake that it's
a blatant lie from destiny, Stephen, but people are blindly accepting
it as fact. Do you see how this would be a deterrent to future
victims coming forward? Yes, but I think that needs that needs
to be weighed against my own obligation to put my forward my
honest opinion which I believe to be true. Uh I think if you're
putting forward your honest opinion and you refuse to go into
your archives to exact to actually go to your base level for
why you believe that opinion to be true, you are a hack loser.
Okay, I hope Dev's watching. Dev, if this is the case that you
feel like it's your obligation to put your honest opinion forward
and you're unable to cite that, you're unable to go to this thread
and and say this is why I believe this, you are a hack loser,
right? Obviously,
he says he has it archived and he won't just post what he has
archived to make him believe this. Coming at it from the angle
of they both did bad is so unbelievably sad. It's just like how
much would you have had to have your head in the sand to come
to that conclusion? You'd have to basically know nothing and
only be guided on what Destiny is saying. I forgot I was supposed
to be nicer to Dev while I did this cuz I I want him to come
on stream, but like what what is happening here? Yeah, but then
he'd have to learn things. It's far easier to live in ignorance
when you don't know anything. But Dev Dev is like a smart person.
This ignorance is like the ignorance is beneficial to him just
as it is to everyone else. To be honest, Kelly, um my my assumption
is that Dev is feigning this ignorance because it is profit.
it will be profitable and he understands it will be profitable.
Even if he's not a prophet, it's still beneficial. It's always
that to me is the most likely scenario here because he's not.
Yeah.
Yes. Deb is a very intelligent person. It's fine.
Anyway, what do you mean there?
I didn't. Do you think this is true generally for people making
Oh, sorry. Yes, but I think so. I need to put my honest opinion
forward. Do you think this is true generally for people making
allegations of misconduct? They should come forward with it if
they feel it to be true regardless of the strength of the evidence
for and against it.
Uh, did you just make another great point? Like, hey, do you
think that it's your obligation to just say what you feel in
your heart? Are you not just saying like my I I listen, I felt
like I was being abused, so I should be able to put out a thing
saying I was abused, right? I feel like I'm abused. Yeah, I don't
have evidence for it really, but like I feel it and I think it's
my obligation to put my feelings out there. She actually just
brutally with that. No,
I hope you know. Oh, wait. Hold on, Germanmanium. Wait, what?
I hope you know that allegation is one of the worst things to
say that only that he's only doing this out of some sort of Well,
hold on, Germanium. I want another explanation here, right? I
want another explanation for why because Dev is intelligent and
I don't see what reason he could have for being this intentionally
obtuse. If he has another reason for being this intentionally
obtuse and and I believe basically this actuallyes when Destiny
man nice to me he he this actually exposes it directly right
you're saying you think it's your obligation to say what you
believe to be true right right here it's it has to be weighed
yes I see how I could possibly like have a negative effect on
victims coming forward right I see that but it has to be weighed
against my own obligation to put forward my honest opinion which
I believe to be true that's cognitive dissonance makes me feel
better about life because I can pretend it good, it fine. I imagine
this is also what makes Lena stay with Destiny, right? It's just
like I don't know all of the bad things and I'm not aware. I
got to just put it to the side. It's like it's fine. I can continue
to do everything and associate with this man. It's all good.
Are you there? Did you die? Yeah. Yeah. Um, so yes, but I think
that so this I had a whole point there and then you kind of cut
in. So I need to uh re-remember what it was. Um, I can't believe
All right. I don't understand
why he'd be doing this. He's smart generally.
Oh, was it uh No, I totally lost it. Anyway, so anyway, um, okay.
She says, "Okay, the thing about um, do you think they should
do that regardless of evidence for or against it?" Hold on. We
can have this discussion first, but what do you have? Wait, no.
That's not that's not how this works. That's not how this works.
This is such insane intentionally intentional lying.
So, Destiny responds to Dev here saying that uh this person has
nothing. They became a deranged Andy fan a couple years ago.
It's easy to say whatever you want online. It's a lot harder
when you're under oath. There's a reason they wanted that transcript
sealed and I want the transcript open. Um, no. Destiny actually
wants all private information about anybody accusing him or anything.
Um he he wants to publicize it as much as possible. He absolutely
wants to chill any speech against him 100%.
Okay. All right. So we have the dev discussion. I think that
continues with Ellie B. It does. Uh wait, hold on. I think he
continues discussing with her. Oh no, he doesn't. Oh, that also
looks pretty bad. Sorry. Uh I wonder if he scrolled my timeline
and saw that what I have, including court filings, which are
literally under penalty of perjury. And that's why he's responding
behind a block so his fans can't see. He's lying. Oh,
wait. Destiny responded to this. Oh, he's like a little He's
like actually totally made. He can see the le person responding
to him and he's actually totally made and is going through her
replies and going through this dev thread and going and responding.
Oh, he's like a cool. Amazing. Destiny, unblock me so I can start
quote tweeting your lies. Destiny, unblock me so I can quote
tweet your lies, loser. Hey, unblock me. Unblock me. reply to
her behind a block. Okay, I'm just I'm saying Destiny can unblock
me. He can stop being a little [__] Hey, Destiny,
stop being a whiny. Unblock me, loser. Unblock me now. Unblock
me. Stop being a Okay. Should I start dictating like actually
what people should write as responses to him? I think I should
I should start saying like basically what should be responded
to and people should be able to quote tweet him and we're going
to we're going to actually juice those cuz he's like he's totally
disingenuous and people don't know it well enough to to point
out where he's lying about things.
Okay. So, uh, here.
Wait, doesn't Ellie Ellie responds to some of this? Hold on.
Where do I have her responses to this? Cuz she actually talks
to him, doesn't she? Where are her responses to him? Oh, she
talks way too much. Hold on. I I'll never get through there.
Where are her responses to him? Oh, right here. Here it is. Here
it is. Okay, they actually have a back and forth here. Cute of
him saying all of this behind a block. Bro is spiring hard. He
used to at least unblock me when he wanted to talk in order to
keep me from criticizing him. Uh, question mark. Oh, good. I
have some questions for you. With how many women have you relied
on implied consent to share of ballpark if you're not sure? Was
Kylo lying when she said you couldn't remember whether you gave
consent? Uh, 4,000. Oh, Destiny just starts memeing. Right. So,
Destiny gets totally again and he just starts memeing. He He
totally redirects out, right? It's so funny. It's so funny. Okay,
so he says 4,000 of every single multiple personality your mom
cast counted as a different person. Your mom joke. I can't imagine
why you wouldn't want to answer. Implied consent is a legitimate
form of consent, right? And he memes again. So, just to be clear,
Kylo was lying when she said you didn't remember Pixie gave consent.
Probably not. I know you enjoy laring as a teenage boy, but this
is a serious matter. That's the reason you're engaging this conversation
after all. You know it. If this is a serious matter and the answers
are important, if I'm sure you're looking forward to seeing the
transcript as much as everyone else, why would that be? Hold
on. How is that relevant to either of these things? Is the transcript
going to tell us whether Kylo is lying? Is Kylo testifying there?
Does the transcript tell us how many women you've relied on this
question or relied on this answer for or relied on this implied
consent argument? How many women's have you sent? Just going
like I think they'd be fine with it. Can you zoom in a little
bit? Yeah. So, oh, here's the transcript. The transcript to your
procedural hearing contains the answer to the question of whether
Kylo is lying about what she told Tom about you or how many other
women you spread of based on implied consent. Must have been
a wild hearing or you've just found a new thing to cling to to
deflect from all the allegations against you in a desperate attempt
to save your career and prevent your further other victims from
coming forward. Who can really say? He shouldn't have unblocked
this person. Okay, because he got absolutely by this person.
I It's actually embarrassing for him. Uh, now it's deep in reply,
so people probably aren't going to see it, but she's just totally
obliterating him, and it's very, very, very funny to me. The
nice thing about hearings is that you're you are sticking your
name and your reputation on the things you're being said, uh,
you're saying as being true. No one knows or cares who you are
on this platform. You'd be an idiot to expect serious engagement
here once this has gotten to the litigation stage. Thanks for
playing, though. This whole thing was you responding to dev and
involving yourself in this thread. Why would you come and involve
yourself with this person if you weren't worried about the things
they're saying? You literally join this thread to discredit them.
He comes in and he goes, "Hey, this person shouldn't be trusted."
And then she's like, "Oh, cool. Can you answer some questions
for me?" He's like, "Uh,
the cool thing about not being on Twitter is that I have to tell
the truth when I'm not on Twitter. I'm going I'm leaving." Okay.
I Why did you interject? Why did you involve yourself? And then
you got baited into unblocking her. Got completely And I'm guessing
you'll reblock her again. Sad. Very sad. The nice thing Oh, yeah.
Sure. Sure. Okay. So, for instance, court filings have significantly
more credibility. The nice thing is we all have access to those.
Cool. Oh, wait. That's so all the court filings where people
put, you know, where they were under penalty of perjury in the
same way they'd be in court, right? They're under penalty of
perjury. Oh, so the the statement from Abby where she says you
sent her videos of Pixie in 2023. That's way more reliable than
anything you'd say on Twitter or on your stream. Perfect. I love
that world. Let's Let's stay in that world. Okay. So, we have
that. We have multiple women saying you sent non-consensually
in sworn statements in sorry in statements under penalty of perjury
the same way they'd be under penalty of perjury in court. I'm
so glad that Destiny wants to operate in that world. I love that
world. That world is very clear to me where people actually have
credible allegations and they're putting their their reputation.
They're putting their on the line. Yeah, I love that. Let's operate
in that world. Very cool. He just But but by the way, um when
when Abby does that, she's perjuring herself. She's being encouraged
by Pixie and lawyers and then Pixie is being encouraged by me
and Lauren de Laguna and who knows who's encouraging me and Lauren
de Laguna might be the guy's so cute and onrained that he can't
even see how absurd his statements are, right? He's like, "Oh,
actually, you should just trust the things that are done in the
litigation stage. You should trust those." Yeah. Pen statements
under statements under oath under penalty of perjury. Those are
really reliable
encouraging you before. Uh, sure. And the funny thing is is I
believe so we'll see what the transcript says but I believe he
says he does he say he had consent. I believe that when we get
through this there might be some examples of things where he's
uh he's sort of walking a very fine line. I think it'll be very
embarrassing for him. The funniest thing the funniest thing with
Desty saying Abby was guessing. Surely it seems really weird
to me how people like make these guesses after they uh after
they Destiny about who else he's and then they guess 100%. Right.
You'd think they'd miss, right? Like Destiny goes and he eats
Lav out and then suddenly Lav knows a bunch of people Destiny's
Destiny Destiny Abby and then Abby knows a whole bunch of people
Destiny's made videos with and right. Wow. That's just shocking
to me that somehow
Destiny's Destiny's Seaman somehow imbuss upon other people knowledge
of all of his other encounters. That's very crazy to me. They
just get 100% guess rate. That's wild. It's almost like, and
that's, by the way, that's a way more reasonable explanation
than he's just a who likes to brag about other people and or
send videos to people of other people. Let's not forget. Hold
on a second. Hold on a second. He told us about this. Let me
go find the raw clip real quick. Uh, is it here? I think he sent
me a file with it. Uh, where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
It was on my It was on my last
Oh, it's the Bob 7 clip. Do I have a Do I have a thing? I need
to open this clip and then walk away for a second. It's the Bob
7 clip. Ry, if you're watching, send it to me. If not, Kelly,
I need to walk away. I need to use bathroom real quick. Get some
water. And also, it's like a thousand degrees in my room. So,
I'll be right back. It's all you for a second. Oh, brilliant.
Why are you running? See, money, you just save random things
sometimes. I don't know why.
I don't understand half of them.
I just lost my enthusiasm.
I think I might just go to bed. What do I think about this guy?
I don't know. It's just another Sorry, not talk. What did you
say? All you said was hi. Am I supposed to respond to every person
that says hi? Oh, damn. Never done that, but surely I'll have
a personality change or that becomes the case. No, just saying
hi is not being nice. It's just saying hi. I mean, you can say
hi. Just expecting me to respond to everyone that says hi would
be stupid. I read out the person that said an actual nice message,
which was composed of a whole sentence earlier. So, not even
true. I mean, I also ignore the people that just say a you as
well. If you want me to respond to your insult or your compliment,
probably make it more creative. I don't know. Billy, I appreciate
all you do to contribute to the content.
What is that? Out of curiosity. Okay, I'm back. Hello. Hello.
I watched that video, the chronic fatigue one. I don't I think
she probably has something that's worse than chronic fatigue.
Did uh did Substance send the other video? Substance said he
was going to send the video, the aerodyite video. Oh, I don't
Was I supposed to look for that? Uh Kingler92. I have no idea.
I literally he So, I'm just saying that he'll say that I'm totally
unhinged. He talks about me like coordinating with Kiwi farmers,
helping people get doxed. He he he says a whole bunch of things.
I just love him to source that or source where he believes I'm
like getting witnesses to purge with themselves or source where
he believes I'm like coordinating with Pixie to do something
like in terms of like something dishonest. He just paints me
as dishonest constantly and can never ever ever show a screenshot
or show a clip, right? Why is he allowed to just totally make
things up about me whole cloth and never ever ever
have to prove any of it? He just says I do these things but he
doesn't show proof, right? And I'm I'm kind of sick of people
just saying, "Oh, well, I'll believe him until you can show me
you didn't do it." That's insane. And as far as I can tell, the
only reason to take that position for people who can normally
argue fairly intelligently, the only reason to take that position
would be because you're looking at the monetary incentive for
taking that position. Oh, here the uh here the video of what
Aerodite said on the Turkey Thompson. I confronted him in Miami
in like early December when I went down in person cuz I wanted
to talk to him in person and I was like, "What the is this?"
Um, and I asked him, "Did she know you're recording?" And did
she Yeah, only I'm literally covering something else right now.
Uh, I I'm aware that Israel's attacking Iran. I'm not covering
it right now. Consent to it. Um, he said that she did know about
the recording. Like she's aware she did consented to the actual
filming of it, but that he said specifically probably not. Um,
like it was 3 years ago. I don't remember specifically and like
things were open like this, but yeah, probably not. I didn't
get like explicit consent. And I said, "Stephen, that's reallyed
up. Like that's not okay." Um, and so just to be clear, by the
way, we're going to watch a video after this where Erdite says
she regrets this Turkey Tom interview. I think this is the reason
she regrets the Turkey Tom interview completely, right? I think
this is the reason because she came out and said, "Oh, Destiny
told me this." So most people would say, "Oh, she regrets the
Turkey Tom interview because she's like getting attacked or something
now." I think it's like she regrets it because of this. And she
also said, "Here's some lines for like where I'll disassociate
with Destiny." And she disassociated with him for like bridges
and [__] Right. I think that's the she regrets having
a professional disassociation with Destiny that she doesn't want
anymore that she wants to be doing bridges with him again. I
think that and then this right here where she where she hurts
his case. Now, I think I think it's incumbent on Ardite. She's
given testimony here that I think would be very valuable in court.
Hey, could you tell me exactly what was said? Could you tell
me? Could you could you come speak in court under oath about
exactly what was said here? Why did you say this? Right. Why
did you say this? Or or what do you think has Destiny talked
to you? What do you think Destiny's what do you think Destiny
saw that changed his mind on this? What happened exactly? He
probably he would say I didn't completely say um but I read that
very strongly as him acknowledging that he did not have consent
to give it. Right. Okay. I confront. Okay. Okay. So I forget
Destiny's oh is apparently is certain he never gave Pixie consent.
Yet the this answer Kyla gave in her interview with Turkey Tom
over her initial conversation with Destiny after the leaks were
posted on KF quite clearly demonstrates that Destiny actually
doesn't remember. Oh, that's another good point, right? That
he says he doesn't remember at all. So how does he know that
he didn't give Pixie consent at all when he says, "Oh, I don't
remember for sure." Back here
when cloud farming backfires, I'll just point out, "Hey, Ardite.
Erdite thinks I hate her. thinks I well I definitely don't like
her. But um I gave her the advice when I heard that she'd interviewed
with Turkey Tom. I said, "Hey, if that's not posted, you need
to cancel that. You need to ask him not to put that up." And
she was like, "No, I don't think that's smart." I was like, "Okay,
well, good luck. Don't go don't go do this interview. That would
be really dumb." I think I told her I think Tom would have done
it. He would have taken it down. He would have said, "Okay, if
you don't want to put up, that's fine." And before it was published,
I said, "Hey, go don't let that get published. You're going to
get that's going to be up. You need to wait until information
comes out. Don't make a Don't make strong statements a day after
this happens. You're going to look unlucky. Guys, how do you
know what she said? Uh, I don't know if I know what she said.
I think I'd have to go look at my DMs with her. Maybe my DMs
are here. Hold on. I'd have to go see exactly what it was. Let
me let me check. Let me check real quick. Not so aerodite. Uh,
what does this have? Oh, is she on Hold on. I just need to check
something. Don't worry about it, guys. Don't worry. It's not
not important. You guys don't need to care. Oh, I can't. She's
She's on a Wick panel right now. I was I I saw she was in some
channel that I can see. I was like, "Oh, I wonder if I should
go ask about it." I probably wouldn't do that. I don't know.
It'd be pretty funny. She's I just thought she was in some channel
that I can see. Um,
not so aerodite. I'm just I'm curious what I said there. Why
I said it, but I remember that explicitly.
what did I say? I think it was Tom announcing it and I just said,
"Hey, you should make sure you know what's going
I think Oh, what did I say? I said, "Hey, if you're going and
giving public interviews, you should make sure that you like
have gotten answers from Destiny on what exactly you're going
to think cuz if you haven't talked to him about any of this,
you're going to be in a really rough spot. Like if or or if you
um if you can't like get an opinion from him that you'll see
like changes over time." I I don't think I actually told her
not to do it now that I now the look. I thought I did, but I
Yeah, I have to see the order she went in.
Anyway, I thought I did. Apparently not. Okay, what are we doing
now? We're moving on to I think we've done the whole the whole
Elie thread. I always want to say Eli Eli, but I think it's Ellie.
Ellie B. Okay, you can end the Sherrod right now by just providing
what you have. If you did have something that would denigrate
Destiny and vindicate his accusers, you'd be hurting them by
not providing it. Wait, the thing she has is all of Wait, hold
on. The thing we all have is his message saying explicitly, I
violated her consent in the most egregious way possible and then
him saying, I have no idea if I got her consent. Yeah, obviously
these things are together. Why does Kyla get more hate than Dan
when they don't basically equally sleep uh sweep? Because Dan
doesn't make moral claims about himself and like the he believes
really like with regards to this. He's basically said, "Yeah,
I'm going to stick by my friend even though I think he did wrong."
He literally said, "I think he did these things and I'm going
to stick by him." Kylo says, "Oh, no, no. I think um I think
it's misunderstood. I think there's like things that Destiny
hasn't been able to make public and you know, even even then
I'm like not going to I'm not going to like move away from him."
Herit does a lot of arguing, a lot of political debate, which
is arguing like moral philosophy essentially, right? I don't
believe her moral philosophy lines up with the with continue
to support Destiny. I I just don't think it does. Her stated
moral philosophy, she like has these exceptions. So, she doesn't
make like I and again, I'd have to maybe go through stuff. The
the impression I get is she doesn't really have moral rules.
She sort of has like some moral rules and then she has exceptions
like if I'm really good friends with you, I will never abandon
you. And that like overrides any of the other moral rules, right?
But but she doesn't really state it that way. She says like I
don't believe on giving up on people and she won't like denounce
or or really admit the things that are wrong. Like Dan's explicitly
said I think that this happened, right? Oh, sure. Right, J. Exactly.
So, she was willing to cut Chud logic off from going on the Anything
else podcast because of his morals, which by the way, significantly
less bad than the Destiny was doing. Significantly less bad.
Okay, I know what the actual underlying situation there is that
Aerodite was claiming Chad had no morals for. It's like infinity
less bad. Arerodite's actual morals are if you treat me badly,
you are evil. If you treat me good, you are good. That's the
only underlying morals that she has or morality only underlying
morality. You treat me good, I like you. You treat me bad or
your community treats me bad, I hate you. You suck. You are an
evil person. Uh I believe that is actually I believe that's actually
another thing. It comes up again in this next thing is she she
literally is like she'll talk about in this Ryal video. She will
say uh that she's not talking. So, she makes a comment about
people's morality and then somebody says, "Dest, you're talking
about Destiny." And she goes, "No, I'm talking about how people
treated me after the Destiny stuff happened." That's actually
what she's talking about. It's crazy. Uh, exactly. Any Duro suffer
the same fate in different spectrums. If they both just admitted
what sides they were sticking by, obvious to everyone, they'd
probably get less hate. Um, I don't think that's the case with
Nicholas. Uh, I think I think Nicholas is like there's like a
blindness that happens for Nicholas that he is normally not a
victim of, and I don't think he's like um emo Uh, sorry. Morally
like bankrupt in the same way. I just don't see it quite the
same with Nick. Yeah, the queen with the cute guy is going to
hate Nick, though. Obviously,
obviously.
That's okay. Okay, what else do we got tonight? Do we have anything
else on this? I'm trying to think of what else I wanted to do
on this. I think I'm just going to go to those airday videos
probably since it's right here. But I don't know. I don't know.
Let's see. Trying to see what else I got for the night. Maybe
I'll just do the airday video real quick and then I and then
it's on to probably for tonight. Maybe commentary Civil War stuff.
Oh, is my clock not showing up on stream? Oh, the clock isn't
showing up. What the hell? The clock's like over here. What the
two hours? Guys, we are two subs away from another hour on the
stream. Okay, if you guys like the content, you want to donate
towards getting more content on the stream. Okay, you can go
ahead. You can give subs kick. You can sub up. You can sub with
Prime on Twitch. You can donate through Kickbot or through Streamlabs.
I'll put the Kickbot link in both chats. Okay. Oh, Branchie.
Sorry, Branchie. I didn't see this earlier. I've not kept up
to this at all. Is there any actual actionable evidence from
either side here? What do you mean actionable evidence on on
the pixie like lied under oath thing or something? I don't I
don't think so. There's no actionable evidence
Oh, thank you very much Sophia for the beat for the two subs.
Let's go based. I'll have to put the link in both chats and then
one second here. I resubbed on Twitch earlier. Got no not got
no notification. I could have subbed. Okay.
Um, I don't know what you're talking about by actionable evidence
here. Maybe I'm wrong here, but there was not was there not logs
from to Rose from Destiny about the plaintiff's video where he
mocked her ability to perform something like uh, yeah, there
there are Simpson Aoy. Sure, that could be another thing they
want sealed. Sure. So, I went back through Twitch chat was just
answering old Twitch chats here cuz I didn't have it up or something.
Who is LA? I don't know this person. I don't know that I know
they basically have been following the case and making arguments
against Destiny. They're one of the only people on Twitter who
actually have like any knowledge about it. It's crazy. Sorry,
what am I doing? adding more time on the stream. That's what
we're doing. Can I reset this? Resetting these.
What is it now? It's Sorry, I'm resetting all my timers and stuff
here real quick, guys. Just give me a second. Okay, the Riyle
Aerodite video real quick. And then I think maybe we'll go to
Israel after this. Where's my Riyle video? My Riyle Aerodite
video. And then we'll go to Israel. And then I don't know. We'll
see. $59.
Here's the Ryerite video right now. Let's see. Let's see what
gets said here. Is there any opinion that you have expressed
in the past that you regret? Ooh, any opinion I've expressed
in the past that I regret? Probably.
Um, I basically wholly regret doing the Turkey Tom interview.
Um, not even all the opinions in there. I just regret doing the
Turkey Tom. I think it was a terrible uh terrible life choice.
It was It was really dumb. Well, people I'm really trying to
just I don't when it comes to like the character of a person,
I really don't care about what you believe typically. Uh-huh.
Uh I care about the way like you go about it. Right. So like
if you believe in something that I think is like Yes. She's just
laid out the argument for thinking Nick Fentes is a great person
possibly, right? I don't care if you believe run the world. I
just care about how you go about it. If you're polite about Listen,
if you're nice to me while you think run the world, I really
don't have an issue with that. Just be nice to me. Just be nice
to me.
Awful.
Um, I'm talking about destiny. No, hold on. Listen to the whole
thing again. I'm really trying to just I don't when it comes
to like the character of a person, I really don't care about
what you believe typically.
Uh, I care about the way like you go about it, right? So like
if you believe in something that I think is like awful, I'm talking
about destiny. No, I'm not talking about destiny right now at
all. No. Oh, look. Destiny. Uh, that's a actually a good point.
Why did you bring up You brought up the Turkey Tom interview.
That's why people think you're talking about Destiny. Destiny.
Destiny up. But, uh,
yeah. Was it really bad? Tell me. Tell me what he did was bad
and and then no other further actions or possibilities from there.
Just tell me it's bad and end all descriptions of Destiny. Listen,
he did a bad thing. What do you want me to say? That's all I
want from Ardite. Please just say the line that you've said a
million times before that actually means [__] nothing.
Please. I just want to hear her be [__] [__]
H. Yes. Be
um all of Destiny's ups are unfortunately
not good. And also um she said not good. She didn't say bad.
She said not good. They're not good. I didn't get I didn't Oh,
I really thought she'd say bad. We were almost there, guys. Most
of them are actually well within the realm of like kind of what
I expected. But I also have a pretty complex understanding I
think of Steven. It's Yeah, I basically expect Listen, I basically
expected him to,
you know, record people without their consent. I expected him
to send a bunch of people without their consent. And why wouldn't
he why wouldn't she expect that, guys? Why wouldn't she expect
So, I have this time stamp in my history, okay? And it's just
like it's so so obvious. All right,
we talked about Okay, so a long time ago. Why wouldn't she expect
it? Because here's the thing that we all need to understand.
This isn't the first instance of Destiny sending to other people
without the other person's consent, right? He is he has done
this multiple times before.
So Erin's listen.
We should all expect this. But doesn't this kind of make Pixie
correct in nearly every way? Right? If Destiny, if Destiny has
just consistently been violating people's consent, sending their
non-consensually for years and has never stopped and has continued
to violate even the people who got mad at him. He's contined
to violate their consent over and over and over again. Doesn't
he need some kind of legal consequence to stop? Clearly, like
social consequences have never stopped him. So sometimes, so
obviously, okay, me and Lena send people me and had a conversation
about there were a few girls we talked was like, "Oh, cool. Like
we should record videos of like us going to send his people like
it's fun." So we do this. Um, I kind of like have like my little
archive of like material that I'll send to people if I want to.
Um, there were girls that I talked to um, past that that I'd
send stuff of like either me or me and Molina. And Molina talked
to me and she was like, "Hey, um, if you're going to send any
videos to um, new girls that we haven't talked about, like let
me know that first." Um, because she wanted to be careful. And
I was like, "Okay, sure." That was fine. I didn't think about
it at the time because I didn't think it mattered. But, uh, I
didn't think about it at the time because I didn't think it mattered.
But uh but you know when my life when my wife was like hey maybe
don't send of me non-consensually to people well then it really
dawned on me that that might not be okay. Yeah sure. So I thought
about that. So that was like an issue that me and Molina had
that we talked about and then we resolved. Right. Which by the
way this is from the Bob 7 manifesto I believe. Right. Bob 7
Bob 7 makes allegations. This is from the Bob 7 manifesto. One
of the things he says is a nuke on Bob 7 is the fact that Bob
7 screen record shared nudes of other people to other people.
Right. Without their explicit consent. That's one of his notes.
That's one of Sorry, that's one of his nukes. This is pre-ro.
Yes. And he sent videos of Molina non-consensually two rows after
this. So Molina said, "Hey, I want you to understand that's why
Molina has the best case here, right? That's why because he is
on video saying Molina actually explained to me that she I needed
her explicit consent to send those videos to other people and
then he violated her consent explicitly." Right? Is that not
an argument for malicious intent? Hey, you don't have the right
to spread these videos of me. Yeah, you
It's too bad that probably he has like other really compromising
on Molina that, you know, if she if she sued him, he would just
leak or something, right? And and then he's got absolutely than
his audience who would believe that because Molina is a bad person
or done bad things that he's allowed to just send her non-consensually.
Like, I can't imagine any more position than being like, "Well,
Molina sucks. So, actually, when Destiny shared her non-consensually,
she deserved that." Like you're actually such a loser. I hope
you have a hard time sleeping at night. Okay. I hope you stub
your toe. I hope you stub your toe tomorrow morning if you believe
that cuz you're a loser. Yeah, Kingra. But that's that's not
that's not a reason why she shouldn't come forward with this.
And it's not a reason why she shouldn't do anything. Did Pixie
do anything bad? No, I don't think Pixie did anything bad. Well,
Pixie is doing Apparently Destiny's convinced people that Pixie
is doing something evil now, which is shocking to me, but whatever.
Whatever. You know, it is what it is. I don't know why Molina
has to have done something bad versus she just doesn't want to
deal with Destiny's harassment again after escaping it like nearly
two years ago. Um, yeah, that I mean that could be it. I sorry,
but I'm assuming that so she said she wanted to leak stuff of
him when they were getting divorced or that she would like right.
I don't even think she's denied that that she True. According
to him and he listen, he could totally be lying. Actually, that's
a great point, Kelly. According to him, do you think that that's
untrue? You don't think she would have said like, "Hey, I'm gonna
tell people everything." You You think that's unlikely? I think
you would say you just based on the framing and the context.
You would say you just don't. Yes. I don't know the context.
Then it's a worthless statement and it's likely likely being
manipulated. Yeah. No, you're probably right. See, Kelly, that's
something that was in my brain as a thing that happened. And
it shouldn't be. It shouldn't be the Willene thing. Yeah. The
Will Nef thing is probably bad, but just so you know, that doesn't
make it wrong. Or so it doesn't that doesn't make it okay to
share her stuff non-conensually. It doesn't mean that she shouldn't
be able to sue for doing that non uh non-conensually. Having
that done to her non-consensually doesn't mean any of that obviously.
Yeah. Also, it wouldn't necessarily be illegal. If you show something
to someone on your phone, it's not distribution of revenge.
It could just be, for example, if there wasn't consent there
anyway. We don't really know anything about that situation. It
would be it would be Yeah. Yeah. But it wouldn't necessarily
or illegal or distribution. Anyway, so Erid saying, "Yeah, I
guess I just expected this." I don't know. Probably most people
probably expected that when he did this and Molina was like,
"Hey, sending stuff without my consent really
Okay, a lot of people argued that he should have known from there
or the purpose of bringing it up, King Gedra, rather than to
make a argument like that dev guy was making earlier. It's like,
oh, we have to if if the woman did something slightly bad, that
means they're equally bad. That's what all of these arguments
come down to. It's like, we got to try and destroy the character
of the woman so that the heinous crimes we committed against
her are okay. It's like off. Uh it's not even it's like not even
that. What they'll say is like they'll basically try to do this
like appeal denialism. Like I don't care. Maybe I would care
if they were like the only if they were like the victim here
poorly, but because they did something bad, I don't care. It's
like I don't really care. I don't I just don't care. I just don't
really care, you know? Well, especially since the only reason
why all of that was blown up was because of Destiny in the first
place taking shot at Will Nef's girlfriend. Nobody would have
known otherwise. People knew from the Darius thing. It was It
definitely got traction on LSF when it was just the Darius thing,
but that got deleted, I think. Yeah, it got nowhere near as much
traction. And Darius is also insane. So, but the re reason why
everyone like commonly knows cuz people just assumed Darius was
lying. I didn't see you telling the truth. Why the would you?
Um,
I mean, I assumed it was true, but I just It would just be a
weird thing. It would just be a really weird thing to make up.
Like, Darius does lie, but generally with stuff like that, he
doesn't just make up things whole cloth. He's not a very good
creative liar. You know what I mean? I wouldn't say he's trustworthy.
He's just not very good at creative writing. So, I just wouldn't
expect him to make that up out of nowhere. I mean, he's said
a bunch of untrue things because other people have told him untrue
things before. I don't He's not a reliable narrator in any way.
Either way, no one gives a what Darius says. Sure, sure, sure,
sure, sure. Okay, we should continue on with this video. I backed
it up a little bit so we can catch up to where or so we get context
on where we were here. Most of them are actually well within
the realm of like kind of what I expected, but I also have a
pretty complex understanding, I think, of Steven. It's more like
people acting towards me and others in ways that I really didn't
expect. That's been very disappointing. Listen, I expected Destiny
to do all those things. It's really mostly about how people have
treated me and others, but me and others, but me.
But me, guys,
That's so stupid. And God, I wish I wish I wish some private
conversations could be made public is what I wish. Okay. I just
wish some private conversations could be made public. Like who?
Um, I really can't say conversations about um, Aerodite basically,
but they can't with other people. Uh, somewhat. I I really can't
get more specific. There's some other stuff there where uh, cuz
I I'm just I'm just, you know, feeling that. I'm feeling it.
And I I feel compelled to say my opinion. Exactly. Sorry. That's
what's happening.
Yeah. No, here's the thing, Luke Recluse. I don't even know.
She does hate Queman, but she has like a special unique hatred
for me that is like totally unhinged like and not not tied to
reality in any way. Like she despises me in a way that she doesn't
despise Queenman, which is very very surprising to me. Um yeah,
it's just it's very weird and I don't know. I don't know exactly
what's going on there, but like she really really thinks I'm
disgusting. It's very funny. Like she's said it before, right?
She's mentioned me a bunch of times on her stream and I don't
know. I don't know why and I don't know what her basis is.
Doesn't she hate all drama frogs? Maybe it's that.
What he means is probably an error. Might be. I wish people would
talk about it publicly. I wish she would just say this is what
he's done to me.
She used to like you. She had a video of her dancing your OG
to me. Like what? I don't know what you're on about. You talking
to me or you talking to chatter? You I don't know. I really wish
she would come out and say what he's done to me. What do you
mean? What? Oh, I
So, I get the impression that she talks to people behind the
scenes about what a bad person I am. I get this impression because
people have told me about it explicitly and and I just wish she
would come out in public and say why she thinks that. Yeah. Yeah.
I just wish she would come out and talk about why why she thinks
that, but she doesn't. Didn't she tell? Didn't she tell your
friends when she told them that? Or did she literally just said
Justical is a bad person and then didn't elaborate to anybody?
Didn't elaborate?
I would just love some elaboration. Who speaks like that? Bizarre.
Uh maybe she feels you were a sir and sometimes dishonest like
she said during the Tom Fury talk. Yeah, but I wasn't being dishonest
during the Tom Foolery talk,
which is why Tom's career exploded after that. The only time
I would ever say someone is bad would be a preface to explaining
why I think they're bad. Cuz otherwise, why bother?
Did she elaborate about Chud? No, she's never elaborated about
Chud at all.
Anyway,
so we should continue on with this misunderstanding. I think
of We're getting five seconds through this time. People acting
towards me and others in ways that I really didn't expect. That's
been very disappointing. Um,
yeah. I think people, God damn it. This Queenman guy keeps posting
true things that are so that I but I got to read it now. She
was about to start Bridges with Destiny or continue Bridges with
Destiny and thought she had the world until you came and ruined
poor Destiny's life and by proxy hers. I legitimately think that
is the most accurate analysis here. Destiny, unfortunately, Destiny's
life. No, but I'm saying that's how she sees it is like I came
along and ruin and like betrayed her and Destiny and stabbed
them in the back and ruined everything she wanted in the world.
I think that's actually the reason we could delete you and there
are still a dozen other people talking about it. True.
True. People's reactions to the Destiny stuff have been really
really disappointing by and large. Sorry, just I keep cutting
this off but ways that I really didn't expect. That's been very
disappointing. Um,
yeah. People's reactions to the Destiny stuff have been really
really disappointing by and large. Yeah, I think Destiny's response
is Destiny has been more disappointing.
This is so funny. And um I thought that I thought when we watched
that Mr. Girl talk, weren't her and Connor basically on the same
side that like doxing is just bad? Doxing is bad unless the person
was like mean to me. If the person was mean to me, doxing is
actually good. No, no weapon forged against Sorry. I always try
to use that. I always try to use that line from Ray Lewis. Ray
Lewis used that football player. Never mind. I I need to drop
it. So, she hitched her horse to death's post and was caught
up in a guilt by association thing. I imo. Well, not really.
She could have been safe night, but she kept saying like inconsistent
things in my opinion, right? She would have these like moral
positions on people. She condemned people like Andrew Tate and
others. And I'm not saying Destiny necessarily did things as
bad as Andrew Tate who's like accused of I guess trafficking
and and but like she she will have she'll have smoke for conservatives
who won't disavow the tape brothers, right? But then she won't
disavow Destiny. And I I don't get how she could have smoke for
the conservatives who won't disavow the tape brothers, but she's
all good with being there for Destiny
right now. This is all just how all people who have been kicked
in the head by a horse act. Okay, thanks BB boy. Thank you. He's
an even bigger grifter. He's been on Destiny's show. He's been
on his stream
like since for no other reason than to farm for himself. It's
like he's actively said the stuff that Destiny does is against
his moral values and then has gone and done his show. He doesn't
care. He doesn't give a We start a point goal or sub/donate goal
to make Kelly fat. Oh, I should do that actually. No, that would
be great. I mean, I believe. Okay. make a donut goal for Kelly.
Hold on. Hold on. So, if we hit that $90, I will from that point
on switch Kelly's avatar to fat for the rest of the stream. Okay,
but we got to hit that $90. I was going to go anyway. So, that
seems like motivation to leave.
Kelly, it's a joke. But not really actually donate, guys. But
it's a joke. Kelly, I won't do it. But I will if you donate the
money, guys. Okay, Kelly, you can't leave now. We're just getting
to the good part. We're just getting to the good part. I have
no idea. Yeah. I just don't want you to leave cuz I think somebody
will donate to make you fat. Speaking of grifters, I'm going
to go to bed. Okay. Is that grifting? How is that grifting? Israel
just bombed around. We're so cooked. I know. How is that grifting?
[__] Well, I can at least join my uh regular channel
or whatever.
God, I don't know why. It's like a joke. It's literally just
a joke. By the way, I will point out that earlier tonight she
said I will not do one of two things. And it was furry stuff
and it was what was the other one? There's furry stuff and one
other thing. Didn't include the fat avatar. Okay, that wasn't
a boundary she specified. Also true serewave. I was totally honest
about everything I was saying there. I never lied. There's ERP
in the furry stuff, but there's one other that I can't remember.
Content was better with Meowies. It was better with Meowies.
Meowis can't come on and do it again tonight. We will do that
at some point. I might wait. I think uh Cher's back tomorrow
from vacation, I think. And then Meowies would be able to come
on tomorrow, too. And we could do that whole back and forth.
We'll see. We'll see exactly what we do. The meowy stuff was
funny, but basically there are other things going on with um
pirate software that we'll cover a little bit later, but we might
have to go from this to Israel bombing Iran. Okay. Have been
really really disappointing by and large. We'll have to skip
over. Not good. I don't make mistakes. I make different choices
across a series of parallel worlds. Destiny, no friends, no family.
Serial predator. Jesus.
If Destiny's a serial predator, then
I guess these I guess words don't matter anymore.
I guess good for you. Words no longer
um Do you think it's really unreasonable to call somebody who
sends uh other people's non-consensually a predator that he's
done so um against their explicit like
So, so Destiny sends Molina's non-conensually. Molina says, "That
is really of you. That makes me feel really uncomfortable. Please
don't do that. And then he continues to do it anyway. You wouldn't
qualify that as like a predator in any way? You think it's totally
unreasonable to call them a predator? I think it's really up.
But me personally, like up in a way that I would say probably
more than like oh it's just I don't think predator is bad. And
then obviously the um habitually recording audio non-conensually
would be another thing, right? Seen a couple grinder we've seen
a couple of the Grinder calls. We've seen the the cherry audio.
Obviously, I I'm just saying probably Serial Predator is not
that far off. I'm sorry. To get shocked and and appalled at Serial
Predator is pretty goofy to me. Your matter. Anyways, this is
friend of the stream, Soy Pill. He is somebody newer that I thought
he that he was I thought your take was that he was and that's
why you dumped Destiny. I didn't dump Destiny, right? Like Destiny
and I are still friends. We still talk. We He did bad things.
Listen. Okay, there it is. There it is. I knew it was coming.
Listen, it's bad. What do you want me to say, guys? It's bad.
What do you want me to say? There it is. I knew it would happen
eventually. I knew it would happen. I knew it would happen. What?
He's not a predator um at all. Please stop making words mean
nothing. Yeah. Um
somehow we have to figure out on the left how to say that somebody's
doing something really wrong and not have to use like the strongest
morally indictable language uh possible. Okay. Well, somehow
we as people who used to be a part of the DGG sphere have to
figure out how to not minimize really really egregious
consent violations into like, oh, it's bad. You know, he did
something bad, right? When you believe somebody's done something
bad and when they continue to do things bad and when they show
no sign of remorse and no sign of trying to make that right,
that wrongdoing, right, then that's probably something somebody
you shouldn't associate with anymore. At least not openly, right?
Am I crazy? like and you should be able to say I wish instead
of saying what was bad she should actually just have to say the
behavior right don't even assign a value to it say yes Destiny
did um he shared without consent and even when those people told
him that they didn't consent to that he continued to share that
without their consent completely disregarding their explicit
right and I'm fine being friends with him despite that I'm fine
with being friends with him yeah I you know I've listened I I've
heard that grinder audio That sounds pretty bad. Sounds like
that guy didn't have any idea he was being recorded. But you
know what? Even if that were the case, I'd still be friends with
him. And when he tells me that he can't answer my questions on
whether or not that Grinder guy consented, I am willing to take
that non-answer and still be friends with him. Cool. Very cool.
All right. Okay. We're continue with this. Jesus any of this.
Not really interested of this. I am so interested in people coming
to me to like talk about and like excuse Destiny's behavior particularly
because and and here's the real particularly because I'm a woman
and I'm close to Destiny. The complex reason why death uh it's
going to be oh they don't they don't get mad at Dan but they
accused me of doing this. Um yeah, true. Dan's basically said
yeah even if he did this even if Dan said I believe he's guilty
of all of these things. I 100% believe he's guilty of all these
things. I'm going to hang with hang out with him anyway. Right.
That's what Dan said like a like 2 days later. Yeah. I think
he's guilty of everything that he's accused of. I think he's
a total piece of [__] I'm going to hang out with
him anyway. And I'm not, by the way, did not try to do the performative
like distancing. Didn't try to performatively like satisfy her
audience, his audience, and um and like his own morals at the
same time. He he he tried nothing. He just said, "Yeah, yeah,
I I think he did all those things and I'm going to stick with
him." Esme to me is like a good friend and complex person full
of strengths and ails and to you he's by and large a a character.
He's a the he's he's destiny. He's not Steven to you. And so
you're wanting me to weigh in on an individual that I have an
extremely complex dynamic and relationship and and thought life
about. I just I like in my head like saying Jeffrey Dmer instead
of Destiny because all of the arguments she makes would apply
equally, right? You could accuse any behavior or sorry, you could
not accuse. You could excuse any behavior given the things she
says. Yeah, I'm not going to abandon them. They're one of my
close friends. I'm not going to abandon them. They're a very
complex character. There are positive aspects to them. It's Sorry,
we shouldn't use Jeffrey Epste. Sorry, we shouldn't use We shouldn't
use Jeffrey Dmer. We should use Jimmy Savile, right? Jimmy Savile,
famous. Listen, yes, it's the counterpoints argument again. Okay.
Why did I not think to do this? Jimmy Savile. Listen, I know
that I could disavow Jimmy Savile, but he's a complex person.
Jimmy Savile famously who built children's hospitals, okay? Helped
fund raise and build children's hospitals, but was in was found
out to be a prolific. And it's like, well, how many kids would
you have to let Jimmy Savile ravage in order for him to build
one hospital? What's the fair trade-off there? That's basically
what Erid's, right? She's saying, listen, they're very complex
person. They have like ne they have downsides, okay? They have
downsides, but the upsides are amazing. I don't know what the
upside is of Destiny. what he does that other people can't that
is unique that makes you excuse um some fairly demonstrabably
bad behavior anyway in a way that would be satisfactory
as a the character version of how you understand him and I just
I don't know how to do it well I think it's really tough because
I don't think there's going to be a satisfying answer and it's
also weird to do it's weird it's weird to have a do you know
what this might be actually fine as an answer If she had just
gone from the beginning and gone, you know what? Um,
I'd probably excuse most things this guy did. If she had a good
understanding that I'd probably excuse most things this guy's
done, and I just shouldn't speak on it. I should just shut the
up. If she decided it was shut the up Friday, she'd get no heat,
right? She just say Pisco did that, right? It worked out for
Pisco. The idea that she would sit here and say things like,
"Well, did Pisco have the opinions on the record that no, never
mind." It's It's again like some of her doxing stuff really.
I don't know how she could be consistent and remain like sort
of close friends with this guy. I just actually don't think it
works. Who is it that said they think NC is in love with Destiny?
Because I think that might be correct. Um Becket was saying that
I think. Yeah, Queen really disagreed with that. Queen got very
upset when that was said. I don't I I understand that that's
like the laziest paint by numbers analysis,
but Destiny is not one person. If she displayed casual empathy
and attempted logistical POV, she'd have a closer opinion to
reality. She's dreadfully obtuse. I thought she said dreadfully
obese, and I was like, dreadfully. Um, yeah, we should back this
up one more time. Uh, she's saying that he's a complex person,
but she doesn't want to do the analysis to like make you understand
her view of him. And I'm like, okay, that's fine. But if you're
like, I I think he's like a good person despite these really
bad things that happened. I still think he's like a good person
who deserves my friendship, but I can't talk to you about why.
If you're going to do that, you should really shut the up from
the beginning. No, I think I think do it well. I think is really
tough because I don't think there's going to be a satisfying
answer. And it's also weird to do. It's weird. It's weird to
have a It'd be like if you asked me this question like about
Nick or somebody else in my personal life. It's really hard to
talk about people that you have a personal relationship with
in a public medium in the way that you can talk about like archetypes
and people that you don't know as well because you could essentially
archetype them and then describe the archetype and it's a little
bit like depersonalized. Why doesn't she add the there's like
archetype archetype archetype arc?
She's she does this sometimes where she she's cutting off a whole
part of the word. Archetype archetype archetype archetype. It's
it's like it's actually takes effort to say it incorrectly in
the way that you can talk about like archetypes and people that
you don't know as well because you can essentially archetype
them and then describe the archetype and it's a little bit like
depersonalized. It's a lot harder to do that when you talk about
somebody that you're like personally friends with. He's stupid.
Okay. Forcing a bunch of boys to cut their hair. Does she think
that Pixie didn't have the same understanding?
Like this is um how else could I put this? This is somebody who
is sort of like brainwash might be a bit too strong a term, but
does she believe that like Pixie wouldn't have had any deep conversations
with him? That some of the other people being Molina wouldn't
have had these deep conversations with him? Does she believe
that she's got like this totally untinted, unbiased view of destiny
that allows her to see him when nobody else can? Why are so many
people who were friends with him, who were in your pretty much
exact position? Why are those people like so against him now?
Is it that like they're all just unhinged, they're all just insane?
Every single one of them. And there are like a dozen now. Every
one of these people is totally [__] insane. Apparently,
nobody has any understanding. She has the perfect understanding
of Destiny and she's totally not like uh under a spell in any
way. Britney Simon. Yeah. Just anybody who's close to him, right?
Like it's it's very disturbing to me that she's like, "If only
you guys understood Destiny the way I did, you would understand
why he's like a good person. He's complex. I understand he hurts
people, but he's also a really deeply good person. He's just
deeply good."
Okay. I want to know what happened with Jasmine and Far. Um what
do you mean you want to know what happened with Jasmine and Far?
Um
I just don't want to ah there's like a little bit there that
I can't reveal at all but um most of it's out there most of it's
public right Destiny had so so Lauren de Laguno was friends with
like Destiny and other people and basically there were arguments
that were happening and Lauren saw things a certain way and Destiny
had recorded private conversations of them violating Florida's
wiretapping statute by the way recorded private conversations
of that with her with Lauren de Laguna and private conversations
with um private conversations with Farah. He had he had shared
those private conversations with people. And when Jasmine rolled
up to some argument they were having and Jasmine said, "Hey,
uh Lauren said this and you're kind of a piece of for doing this."
And Destiny went, "Well, I have a secret recording of Lauren
that shows you otherwise." And then he played the recording for
Jasmine. Jasmine went, "Oh, you're like a psychopath. I don't
want to be anywhere near you. That's incredibly insane that you
have like this like, oh yeah, you're probably right on that conversation,
but actually you're like a totally you're like a total psychopath,
okay, and I don't want to be anywhere near you. You record private
conversations with your friends in order to win arguments months
later, weeks later. That's
weird. That's disgusting. Yeah, miss me with that [__]
bro. I'm out. That's what happened with Jasmine. That's all public,
by the way. A relevant kid on came on the stream and told me
that story. I possibly before this happened. I can't remember
for sure, but yeah, Destiny had had that group in Florida. The
friend group he had in Florida is broken up with like Lauren
and those people. One, because yeah, stuff disintegrated with
Lauren. But part of its disintegration was that he had recorded
like private conversations that he did not inform them he was
recording. I don't even know if the Farro one's out there. Yeah,
the Faroh one's out there because he secretly recorded Farra
and showed that recording to was it Lauren de Laguna to prove
that Far and and Molina didn't like Laura De Lagona, right? Yeah.
I'm just I'm thinking like by the way given that and then the
the messages to Zoe about lab trying to make lab herself. Um
I can't listen every time we get like a little more evidence
about how this guy operates you just realize more and more. Unfortunately,
there was somebody who described this pattern of like turning
women against each other and deriving pleasure from it. And that
guy was just kind of correct about a lot of things and we didn't
realize it at the time. Okay. It's kind of up. That guy was just
way more correct than most people are willing to admit on a lot
of things. Uh, Marty Epstein, thank you for the gifted the five
gifted. Let's go. We were over the two. We were over that previous
two hours, but I need to go back and add the time. Hold on. Where
do I add the time? That's just 25 on the next hour. Thank you
very much, Marty Epstein. Huge gift. 90. Whoop. I'm resetting
the meters for you real quick. Thank you very much, Marty. Yeah,
we we find out that like somebody had a pretty good read on this
pattern that Destiny engages in, right? Just assume he records
everything and will use it to hurt others. He will. Can like
15 of that go to Fat Kelly. Uh 25 of that's going to Fat Kelly,
but Fat Kelly won't be a thing for the rest of the stream if
Kelly's not around for the rest of the stream. Yeah, I should
do I should do uh
I don't think Top Bronson's around to do fat JC, but I would
do that. You have fat fat detective JTO. I'd do a don go for
that obviously. Oh, what is this not showing up correctly? Oh,
what the I did this wrong. God damn it. I did my tip widget wrong.
Oh well. Fat everybody. Well, I don't want Kelly to be the only
one who's fat. That's kind of up if I just make Kelly the only
one who's fat, right? So, I should be fat, too, probably. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. We continue. Dude, we we managed to farm
like what? An hour almost on this Aerodite. Like 45 minutes on
a 4-minute video. That's not bad. That's That's like That's like
all pro numbers right there, right? 4-minute video. We farm like
an hour of content out of it. Let's go. And it's also weird to
do. It's weird. It's weird to have a It'd be like if you asked
me this question like about Nick or somebody else in my personal
life. It's really hard to talk about people that you have a personal
relationship with in a public medium. Yeah. But I think the solution
here is to just stop responding to any comments on it, right?
Isn't that the solution? You just stop responding cuz every time
she responds, then me or Cleman are going to go and review that
response, right? All she has to do is stop responding. Just say,
"I don't talk about Destiny. I don't talk about Destiny. I don't
talk about Destiny. It's super easy. Everybody knows. I guarantee
she's been told a thousand times by different people. Just don't
comment on Destiny. All you got to do is not talk about Destiny.
It's so easy. Is she using a filter while doing this video? She
has um maybe but she has uh like I think colored contact lenses,
right? Some colored contact lenses
in the way that you can talk about like arc types and people
that you don't know as well because you could essentially arctype
them and then describe. So, this is saying you don't understand
why Destiny is the way he is, and I understand. And I I'll never
explain why I know it, but that's why he'll always be my friend
forever. Despite the things he's done, he'll always be the archetype.
And it's a little bit like depersonalized. It's a lot harder
to do that when you talk about somebody that you're like personally
friends with. He's stupid. Okay. Forcing a bunch of boys to cut.
Any thoughts on her comparing to asking about her husband? Um,
I'm just, you know, I think that's a massive W for Nick in that
Aerodite thinks of Nick in the same realm of masculinity and
manhood as Destiny. Before it was like, oh, Destiny was like
miles above Nick. That he put she's putting them somewhere in
the same stratosphere now has got to be a massive W for Nick.
They're here anyway. Okay. Okay. Okay, dude. I think that's uh
that's it. That's it. That's all that's all we doing here. Oh,
perfect. Yes. Uh, I just got a private message that is Yeah.
So, that message I just got I I actually won't reference it at
all. I'll just I'll type back to you. Sorry, I got to respond
to a message really quickly. I just got more evidence that Destiny
shares private relationship details with whatever next girl he's
trying to because that is his way of, you know, uh, what is it
like demonstrating value, you know what I mean? Is he will talk
about other girls in front of other girls. That's like his way
of demonstrating value. Um, as you get more and more points proving
it. Um, unfortunately stuff that's not public. So I just it would
be wrong of me to social proof. That's the one. King Gedra. Social
proof was the word I was looking for. The the phrase I was looking
for.
I'm just I'm so annoyed cuz you hear something from like four
different people and I'm just like
I kind of want to talk about it, but I can't
can't ever
this Pixie legal team. It's not a legal thing. It's not like
a It's not illegal. It's just proof that he's like a piece of
obviously. like a a totally lying disingenuous lizard person
is probably better, right? I understand that seems but basically
like when he says, "Oh, no. I keep my details private." No, no,
no. That would be really disgusting. I say when people ask me
if if I somebody, I just say I don't answer those questions cuz
I need to keep that all private because it's really really really
important that I don't violate like the privacy of anybody else.
That's just a complete lie. Complete and utter lie. He tells
everybody that he ever about every other person he's ever [__]
He's a total piece of Okay. He's a total piece of [__]
You think Destiny's pick will get brought up as evidence in court?
It might be cuz obviously there's an argument, Machico, that
he has said on multiple occasions, at least one occasion, I believe
multiple occasions, that he does he feels nothing about his being
leaked online, right?
Which colors a lot of this case in in a general sense. Like when
he when he sends videos and he doesn't care about his being online,
but then he paints himself as the victim of all this stuff, it
it rings a little more hollow. I'd say it doesn't ring totally
hollow though because obviously his videos of him sucking, which
is different. But
um would you say that if you did reveal the contents of the DM
you just got, would you be able to convince us beyond a reasonable
doubt that he's currently engaging in the behavior he's accused
of and that he is denying? Um it would be
it would be more evidence that when he says I don't discuss sexual
other people's details, he is lying, right? He he will discuss
it with anybody he's ever had even a remotely relationship